قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقدمت على تفجير
منازل عده في منطقه الصفطاوي في شمال
مدينه غزه واظهرت صور جانبا من هذه
الانفجارات هذه منطقه الصفطاوي شمال مدينه
غزه انسحبت الدبابات الاسرائيليه من منطقه
الشارع العام لهذا الحي لكن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لا تزال تستهدف اي احد يقترب
من منزله
في ايضا هناك انفجارات بين الفينه والاخرى
كما ت هذا الحي وهي ناجمه عن تفجيرات
اسرائيليه عددا من المنازل قبل انسحابها
يعني احداث دمار واسع في هذا الحي في هذه
اللحظات كما تشاهدون الان حيث ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اح احرقت ابراجا
سكنيه ومنازل عده في هذه المناطق كان هنا
صوت واسع لاطلاق النار في هذه المنطقه
ويبدو انه كان ناجما عن اشتباك مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بصوره عامه هذا الحي
لازال يتعرض لدمار وانتكاسه واسعه على
مدار الساعه وعلى مدار الوقت .